Welcome everybody. I'm Dr.
Koyman and I will be presenting
this pre-lab lecture for
PPOM-1 OMM Lab Number 28.
This one is about muscle
energy technique of the lower
extremity and will be very
much tied in to the lab
number 27 which is diagnosis
of the lower extremity. As
you learn the diagnoses,
you will also learn about
the muscle energy treatments
when you come to our labs.
Here on the handout, you
can see a review table from
Bates 13th edition on range
of motion of the hip joint
and the potential hypertonic
musculature involved.
You can review that on this
table. On the right hand
side, you can see a heading
called patient instructions
in quotations. And this
gives you some information
about how to speak to your
patient in layperson's terms
when you are instructing
them in various of these hip
movement motions that you
may need to ask them to do.
Okay, so we're going
to pair these first two
muscle energy techniques.
On the left-hand side of
the page, we see muscle
energy technique for a
hip flexion dysfunction
in the prone position.
Here you have the
instructions from the DG
Ivana text, the
fourth edition of an
osteopathic approach to
diagnosis and treatment.
There's a link here to our
medical library
resource for you.
In the picture, we can
see the physician is
standing on the same
side as the side of the
diagnosis, which is the
hip that is flexed, and
taking the patient's
extremity and hip monitoring
here at the innominate
into the barrier,
okay, which is bringing
it into more extension.
Remember, muscle energy
technique is a direct technique,
and you will be engaging
the barriers of motion
to the particular diagnosis.
Therefore, in this case,
if you have a hip flexion
dysfunction. To do the
direct muscle energy technique
treatment, the physician
will place the patient's
extremity in the hip region
into the barrier of extension
that we can see here.
And as is usual with the
muscle energy technique, the
patient will be pushing
down towards their freedom.
In this case, down towards
the table, which is towards
the direction of their flexion
freedom while isometrically
the physician is resisting
that motion. Remember,
you're going to ask your
patient when you are doing
this technique yourself
to use only about 10 to 25
percent of their strength,
not full force. If the patient
is confused and they use
too much force, please
direct them to lighten up.
Please use less force and
just gauge approximately to
that 10 to 20 25% zone. And
that's true for all of the
muscle energy techniques.
They're going to engage
for those three to five
seconds as noted, and they
will fully relax. Make sure
you give them time to simply
fully relax. Make sure
they actually do that.
Sometimes you will find
your patient may still be
tense or holding on with
their muscles. Try and sense
that and encourage your
patient to really relax,
okay, for the brief moment
before you re-engage the
next barrier. And you will
do that several times.
You could do that three to
five repetitions and do
a gentle passive stretch
as you're finishing up and
then reassess as always.
So that's for the hip flexion
dysfunction in the
prone position.
The other diagnosis on the
right-hand side of the page
is for a hip extension
dysfunction is being treated
with muscle energy technique
in the supine position.
We can see the picture here.
The physician is standing
on the same side as the
side of the diagnosis,
monitoring that anterior
superior iliac spine, okay, and
then taking the patient's
extremity as monitoring at
that ASIS. We're working on
that hip joint specifically
for that hip extension
somatic dysfunction. So the
freedom of course is that
right hip in this case
being able to extend so you
can see the physicians taking
the patient's hip joint
into flexion, the barrier.
Okay
in this case the
patient's leg can rest on
the physician's shoulder
you can see here
and then the physician
would be able to
resist easily that
downward pressure that the
patient would engage,
okay, for the three to
five seconds. As
always, as noted here in
point number four, it is
isometric. So iso, the same
metric measure, the same
measure. So the physician
and the patient are
resisting with equal force to
each other. And as noted
with the other technique,
do guide your
patient if they're
overbearing you and
it's too much pressure,
guide them to use
less intense force,
okay? As always, the
patient relaxes fully in
between the sets, and
you'll do several sets until
you get the normal
range of motion that you
want. And you can always
do a passive stretch
gently for many of these
muscle energy techniques
for a few seconds.
Don't make it too
quick. You don't want
to rush through that,
okay? So taking your
time with each of the
steps. Again, this
is available if you
want to click on the
link here through our
medical library, through
the DG Ivana text.
Okay, moving on.
The next pair of techniques
are for hip ad adduction,
okay, as a diagnosis,
and hip AB, AB as in boy
abduction dysfunction. Okay,
so those are the diagnoses.
Muscle energy technique.
We'll start with
the hip ad adduction
somatic dysfunction in
the supine position.
Okay, you can stand at the
end of the table, but slightly
towards the side of the
diagnosis that you're
treating. In this example, in
the picture here, we see the
physician is going to be
treating the right side ad
adduction somatic dysfunction.
as always, muscle energy
technique, a direct
technique. We're taking that
extremity away from the
midline into that barrier, the
barrier being AB, AB as
in boy, abduction. So the
physician's taking the leg away
from midline. And then we'll
be resisting as the
patient tries to bring that
extremity towards the midline,
towards that freedom of AD
adduction. As usual, providing
resistance to three to
five seconds, fully relaxing,
and several repetitions
until the range of motion,
normal range of motion is
accomplished. And a gentle
passive stretch is acceptable
at the end as well. Once
again, the link is available
for you from this resource
noted here. On the other
side of the page here on
the right side, now we have
muscle energy technique
for the opposite diagnosis.
Now, the diagnosis is a hip
AB, as in ABD, abduction,
somatic dysfunction, also
in the supine position.
Okay, here we have the
physician standing at the foot
of the table, patient
lying, supplying comfortably
if they need a pillow,
that's fine. You can see the
physician stabilizing the
extremity on the opposite
side, the non-treated side
and then the side to be
treated, the leg is
clearing the table. Okay, so
that now if the diagnosis
is that the patient likes
to have their hip joint do
more of the ABD abduction
motion, then you can see
the physicians bringing
this extremity crossing
the line over to that
barrier, the barrier being
towards AD abduction.
And then the patient will
be pushing out as usual
resisting okay matching
that resistance with 10
to 25 percent of of their
strength for the three
to five seconds then
fully completely relax
try and sense that in
your partner that they are
actually fully relaxing
and then several
repetitions usually around
three to five repetitions
is fine and then a
slight passive stretch is
always acceptable in
many of these techniques
for muscle energy for
the lower extremity.
Again, the resource is
available for you here.
Moving on.
The next pair of techniques
and diagnoses for muscle
energy will be for hip
external rotation somatic
dysfunction here on the
left-hand side of the
page versus on the right
-hand side of the page, we
have a hip internal rotation
somatic dysfunction,
both of these in the supine
position. We'll start
with this one on the left
-hand side of the page.
Again, the diagnosis
is hip external
rotation, somatic dysfunction.
Again, from DG Ivana,
resources here. We can see the
physician standing on the
same side as the side of
the diagnosis, taking the
patient's extremity, the
right extremity, into both
hip flexion. You can see
that's 90 degrees of hip
flexion and also 90 degrees
of knee flexion. So it's
90 degrees, 90 degrees. The
physician is stabilizing
the patient's knee, her more
cephalad hand, and then
controlling the motion of
the extremity at the ankle,
okay? And this is as the
ankle is moved out or in,
that's actually really just
a handle for creating the
motion actually at the
hip joint itself, which is
what we want, okay? That's
why this stabilizing hand
is helping to create that
arc of motion through the
femur into the hip joint
to go into the barrier of
the diagnosis, which is a
hip external rotation somatic
dysfunction. That's the
freedom, meaning the hip
likes to externally rotate
in the joint which would
be as if the foot is coming
in in this position but
you can see the physician
bringing the foot outwards
right and that's creating
internal rotation of the
hip by bringing the foot
outwards don't get confused
here bringing the foot out
which seems like you're
externally rotating but it's
doing the opposite motion
at the actual hip joint.
If you have any confusion
on this, please do review
this in your pods when you
get to the labs, and it
will become more clear to
you at that time as well.
Okay, so 90 degrees of
the hip, 90 degrees of the
knee for a diagnosis of
a hip external rotation.
If you want to treat
that with a direct muscle
energy technique in a
supine position, you would
take the ankle and the
lower, you know, the leg
here, the ankle, outwardly,
and that creates the
internal rotation barrier.
You're going to ask the
patient to bring their
ankle towards the midline,
immediately here, and
that would be going as
if towards their
freedom of the external
rotation, but there
won't be any motion.
Remember, it's still
isometric as usual, right?
So again, three to
five seconds of that
10 to 25 percent of
their strength that
you're matching and
then fully relaxing.
And then you go
slightly into that next
barrier. Okay, don't
overdo this. It'll be
very small motions
in between each set.
Okay, you'll do it, you
know, until it's repeated
until normal range of motion
is accomplished as noted
here or approximated. That
can be anywhere from three
to five, maybe even six
times as need be to create
that change. Okay, the
resource is available here.
Vice versa, we have the
opposite diagnosis on this
side of the page. In this
case, it's the diagnosis
of a hip internal rotation
somatic dysfunction. We're
going to treat that with
muscle energy technique,
again, a direct technique
in the supine position.
Position is still on the
same side as the side of the
diagnosis. As with the
external rotation diagnosis,
for the internal rotation
diagnosis, we also have the
hip joint and the knee
joint each at 90 degrees, 90
-90. You can see that there.
Again, the physician is
stabilizing with her cephalad
hand at the knee. And then
in this case, for hip
internal rotation dysfunction,
which would be created, if
the doctor were to pull the
ankle outwardly, that would
create the diagnosis of
the internal rotation, but
to treat it directly with the
muscle energy, now the
physician's going to bring that
ankle inwardly, okay? And
as that happens and the
knee is stabilized, what
happens at the hip joint is
external rotation, which is
the barrier, which is directly
engaging the somatic
dysfunction diagnosis of hip
internal rotation in that
supine position, bringing the
foot in while stabilizing
in this 90-90 position of
the hip and knee, takes that
hip joint to that external
rotation barrier, which is
what we want. And then for
the treatment, you ask,
the physician will ask the
patient to push their ankle
to the outside, outwardly.
But there will be no
motion. Remember, isometric.
There will be no motion seen.
But that motion of pushing
outward is as if going
into that direction of
that internal rotation
somatic dysfunction freedom
for that three to five
seconds isometrically.
Again, only 10 to 25 percent
of the strength as usual,
and then relaxing fully.
Okay, and then repositioning
to the new barrier.
Keep repeating. Usually
it's about three to
five, could be six or more
repetitions as needed.
Very precise and gentle.
You won't see huge
motions between each
of the sets, but you
will be engaging that
barrier each time.
And then a gentle passive
stretch at the end.
can be very small. Do not
rush that. It is acceptable.
Here's the link again
if you want to see that
in the medical library
electronic textbook version.
Okay, moving on to the next.
So what we have here is a
table like we had for the
hip. We have a table here
for the knee joint from
your Bates 13th edition.
Range of motion of the knee
joint and potential hypertonic
musculature involved
is noted here for you.
Here in this right-hand
column, this is very useful
as you are going to be
out in your clinical
rotations in your third and
fourth year and in your
internship residency and on.
Patient instructions,
how to speak in
layperson's terms, what
you want them to do to test
certain motions and
the muscles that affect
those motions. Okay,
and here's the link
if you want to go
directly to that resource.
So here we have another
paired motions of a knee,
of a joint, the knee
joint. So on the left-hand
side of the page, we
have, we're working with
a diagnosis of a knee
flexion, somatic dysfunction.
So as you know, that
means in this case, the
right knee, the patient
likes to flex their knee
fully, but they cannot
extend their knee fully.
So the physician
is standing on the
same side, monitoring
at the knee,
controlling at the ankle.
Fingers are wrapping
around to the back
side of the lower leg
near the ankle region.
And again, remember the
patient can bend just fine,
but they can't unbend. Or
in other words, they cannot
extend that knee fully. So
the physician is really taking
this hand, stabilizing
at the knee that likes to
bend. remember that's the
freedom, and is pulling the
patient's right knee into
extensions as much as it will
go. Let's say that the
physician has done that. That's
as much as this knee will
unbend or extend. So that's
the barrier, going towards
the barrier. And then the
patient, the physician will
ask the patient to pull
that leg towards them, as
if towards their hip, which
would be towards their freedom
of knee flexion. Again,
a soul metric. You won't
see any motion. As always,
you're resisting it.
You're only using 10 to 25
percent of their strength
for that three to five
seconds, relaxing fully.
And then the physician tries
to unbend or extend that
knee a little more going
into that barrier. Remember,
the patient likes to
flex, right? So the physician's
trying to extend that
knee with each of the
sets, and then a little bit
of a passive stretch into
that extension to finish
up, and then reassessing
is always good. So that's
the knee flexion. On the
opposite page here on the
right-hand side, we have
the opposite diagnosis,
a knee extension somatic
dysfunction. So again,
what does that mean? In
this case, you can see
the patient is in the
prone position. The
patient likes to extend
the knee, but in this case,
it's the opposite
diagnosis from the other
page. They don't want to,
or they're not able to,
bend that knee joint
as much. So how
to treat it? Again,
you're going to set
up into the various
patients prone,
stabilizing behind the
knee, kind of at the
posterior distal thigh region,
stabilizing the positions
on the same side, and
then cupping under the
anterior distal leg with
the other hand, okay?
Remember, the patient likes
to extend, so they like
to, they would easily be
able to have their leg
and their unbent knee
resting on the table, but
bringing it up into flexion
this way. The patient
just cannot bend that knee
enough. That's the barrier
is the flexion. So let's
say the physician has
brought this leg and their
knee joint into as much
flexion as they can
tolerate. That's, let's say,
that's it. And that's
really not a normal range.
If they could bend their
knee normally it would keep
going a lot more, but let's
say that's the dysfunction,
right? They like to extend
and they can only flex that
much. They can extend
fully, they cannot flex. So
the physician has taken the
patient into that flexion
barrier at this point. The
patient will then push into
the physician's hands down
towards the table, again,
which is towards their
freedom of knee extension, but
you won't see any motion.
Remember, isometric. ISO, the
same metric measure, the
same measure. So the force
is equal between the doctor
resisting the patient's
downward force at 10 to 25
percent of strength as usual.
And then relaxing fully.
Please don't forget that
relaxation fully. Don't
rush through that step. You
know, take a moment to
allow that to happen. Okay.
If your patient's having
trouble with that, do
your best to coach them and
allow them to be able to
know what that feels like
to relax fully before
moving on. And number six
is, yes, please repeat.
It's usually at least three
to five times, could be
six or more as usual,
passive stretch. Okay. And
then the resource here if
you want to click on that.
Okay, moving on to the
next pair. Well, okay,
so we need, we have a
description and pictures for
the next two that are
related. So we're talking
about the tibia itself, the
proximal tibia. So it can
externally rotate and
internally rotate. So we're
going to start with this
diagnosis of a tibia external
rotation somatic
dysfunction, which will be
treated with the muscle
energy technique in the seated
position, as you can see
in the pictures here. Now
we are utilizing a resource
of the Nicholas Atlas.
You can click on
this link and get the
whole resource with
all of the photos,
but here are a few
key photos for you.
These photos assist you
with the physician in the
white coat being the motion
that the physician is
doing associated with the
white arrow. And then the
patient in the dark shorts,
that motion that the
patient is doing being
associated with the dark arrow.
So that can be helpful as
you're looking through the
pictures here. So what
is the diagnosis? Again,
tibia, external rotation,
somatic dysfunction. Here
we're saying that that's
on the left side, so a left
tibia externally rotated
with anteromedial glide.
Okay, so the physician is
seated. You're facing the
patient. Patient's legs
are hanging off the table
comfortably. Make sure
there's enough space right
behind the knee for that
leg to hang comfortably.
Just a reminder of
these diagnostic
parameters. Remember, free.
The diagnosis is external
rotation, which is free,
but internal rotation of
the tibia is restricted.
So that's the opposite
motion, right? What is
free is the anteromedial
glide with that external
rotation as noted here.
What is restricted is
the posterolateral glide.
And by palpation, there
can be tenderness on that
anteromedial joint space
where the physician's
thumb is noted here. There
could be tenderness there
with this diagnosis.
So the leg is hanging
off. The physician is
taking, and you can see the
white arrow here, taking
the patient's leg, okay,
the lower part of the leg
that the physician is contacting
into internal rotation,
okay, which is the barrier.
Because you can see
here, the diagnosis is
external rotation. That tibia
likes to rotate outwards.
The white arrow shows
physicians taking that tibia
and monitoring here to feel
that that is happening,
bringing the tibia to the
barrier of internal rotation.
Once the physician gets
into the barrier, then he
asks the patient to resist,
okay, going outwards. So
you can see the dark arrow
here pointing outwards,
okay, and that's associated
with the patient in the
dark shorts, goes with the
dark arrow, trying to go
towards his freedom, outwardly
towards external rotation.
But the line here between
the two is showing that
the force is being matched.
Again, as usual, that's
that isometric resistance.
Always, always 10 to 25
percent of their strength
the patient should be
using for the three to five
seconds. And then they stop
and relax. relax. That's
the key, that they really
truly relax. And then once
they're completely relaxed,
as noted here, number
six, the physician will
internally rotate a little
more, again, going to the
edge of that barrier. These
are small motions, but
you're going to be learning
and paying attention to how
that feels. And then going
into the next edge of
the restrictive barrier,
okay? And then you can do
that three to five times or
more until you improve
that range of motion, okay?
And then reassess is
always a good thing.
Passive stretching or
engaging for a final time
into the end range of
motion can always be done.
Here's the resource again if
you want to click on that.
Okay.
This is the opposite diagnosis.
Patient is still sitting.
Physician is also sitting
on a chair in front
of the patient so that
the physician can access
the contacts on the
tibia, still monitoring at
that anterior medial joint
space. But this time,
remember, physician in
the white coat goes with
the motions demonstrated
with the white arrow.
This time, we have the
opposite diagnosis of a
tibia. In this case, in
the pictures, a left tibia,
internal rotation somatic
dysfunction. Again,
seated, patient seated muscle
energy technique. What,
as a review, what are the
diagnostic parameters?
So it's an internal rotation,
right? So here we have
a note saying internal
rotation is free, which makes
sense because we name
somatic dysfunctions for the
relative freedom of motion.
The opposite is that
external rotation is restricted.
The other glides that
go with this are, in this
case, posterior lateral glide
is free with internal
rotation, but the opposite
motion of anterior medial
glide, that is restricted.
Note that with palpation,
the patient may also have
tenderness over that
anterior medial joint space
where the physician is
monitoring here. And that
tenderness in that location
was also true for the external
rotation. So just keep
that in mind, that that is
something that's common
for both of the tibia,
external and internal rotations
and other dysfunctions.
So in this case, we
have that left tibia
internally rotated
with posterior lateral
glide association
for the diagnosis.
For treatment, we have the
physician, again, seated.
Here's that engagement of,
you see the arrow going
outwardly, engagement of the
external rotation barrier.
Okay, then the next
maneuver is physician asking
the patient to, again, with
this dark arrow, patient,
dark shorts, goes with dark
arrow, bring their foot
into their so-called
freedom of motion, right, of
the tibia internal rotation.
So you see that dark
arrow is going inwardly
towards the internal rotation.
There's a line between
the two, the light arrow
and the dark arrow, meaning
they're matching their
resistance, okay? Muscle
energy technique, isometric
as always, right? In
this situation, and the
physician resisting that.
Again, if the patient's
overwhelming the amount of
strength that the physician
can resist, please do
coach them to use a little
bit less, maybe towards
the 10% end of pressure
resistance that the patient's
generating versus the 25,
especially if it's someone
who's very strong and the
physician's not able to
resist as fully. You have to
gauge that between doctor
-patient and the strength
differentials that are going
on there. And then here in
this other photo, We see
the physician taking that
foot outwardly again, going
into the next barrier, and
or that could be the last
final engagement, sort of
like a passive stretch or
an engagement of the final
barrier at the end. As we
know here, number seven says
steps four through six can
be repeated three to five
times, sometimes more if you
need to, until the motion's
maximally improved, right?
and then reassessing.
Here's the resource again
if you need to click on
the link available through
our medical library.
Okay, so the next
two are also paired
in terms of their
opposite motions.
We have the fibular head
that we can treat those
two diagnoses with muscle
energy technique. We'll
start with the posterior
fibular head somatic
dysfunction. This is also
from the Nicholas Atlas,
again, available here
through our medical library.
In this case, we're using
an example shown in the
pictures here of the left
side. Here's the patient
supine. Physician is on the
left side of the diagnosis.
Left side, posterior
fibular head.
You can see the physician's
index finger or their
so-called second finger,
index finger, metacarpal
phalangeal joint is
on the kind of posterior
side of that fibular
head here, which is,
happens to be posterior,
physician has that contact
because the MCP joint
there that's contacting is
going to help with a little
kind of a nudging motion
to get that fibular head to
come more anteriorly. Just
a reminder in terms of
diagnosis, remember the
posterior fibular head goes
with posterior and slightly
medially. in terms of
directionality. And when we
get to the other diagnosis
and so-called anterior
fibular head, remember that
diagnosis goes and is
associated with a slight lateral
motion as well. So really,
it's not just anterior
or posterior that the
fibular head is gliding in
terms of a very, very small
preference of that diagnosis.
It is also anterior and
lateral and posterior
and medial slightly. But
for brevity, we do call it
just that it's a posterior
fibular head, but just know
that it's actually posterior
and medial slightly.
Okay, so the physician is
engaging the barriers.
Remember when you
learned the diagnosis
of the posterior fibular
head, you know that's
associated also with
plantar flexion, internal
rotation, and inversion.
Those three motions,
important to know,
go along with a
diagnosis of a posterior
fibular head. Again,
as a reminder,
posterior fibular head,
the motions that go
along with it are the
plantar flexion, internal
rotation, and inversion.
Those are the freedoms.
So to treat this diagnosis
of the posterior fibular
head with muscle energy,
which is a direct technique,
we want to do the opposite
motions of that, which
would be dorsiflexion. We
can see that in number three
here, dorsiflexion, external
rotation, and eversion of
their lower leg and their
ankle, their foot, those
motions will be engaged.
And you can see the white
arrow here is engaging those
motions of the dorsiflexion,
eversion, external rotation.
Then the dark arrow,
remember patients in the
dark shorts, dark arrow shows
the patient's motion,
patients going more inwardly,
right, toward that so-called
freedom of plantar flexion
inversion internal rotation.
And you can see the
physician's hand is underneath
the foot resisting that
motion. As usual, there's
going to be the isometric
resistance, three to five
seconds. Patients will stop
and relax, fully relaxed.
That's important. and then
engage that barrier or
those three barriers again.
And then the whole time,
the physician's also kind
of nudging with that
MCP contact there at the
fibular head. That's kind
of enhancing the treatment
as well. And then repeating
it three to five times.
And then the last time can
be kind of an engagement
of that barrier one more
time and then reassess.
Here's the resource
from Nicholas Atlas
through our medical
library once again.
You'll get more
pictures, but I think
these are the key ones
that will help you.
Now the opposite diagnosis,
moving on to an anterior
fibular head. As we just
mentioned, remember that
diagnosis is associated with
an anterior lateral motion
and vice versa, a
posterior fibular head
associated with a
posterior and medial,
slight medial associated
motion as well.
This is from the Nicholas
Atlas once again.
The example is in the
pictures on the left side,
the left anterior fibular
head. You can see the
physician with the white
coat, the white sleeves
here on the left side,
the same side as the side
of the diagnosis patient
in this case is supine.
Just as an aside, this
treatment here shown supine
And as in the pictures, as
Nicholas Atlas describes,
absolutely, you can do this
supine and the one before,
posterior and anterior
fibular head, somatic
dysfunction, muscle energy
treatments. You could also have
the patient seated and
engaging these motions, these
same motions. You would
just want to make sure that,
you know, they're sitting
just enough forward so
that, you know, their knee
isn't tightly hooked on the
table. They need to be a
little bit forward so their
knee is relaxed and really
hanging off the table.
And you can engage these
same motions and have your
physician's hand contacting
that fibular head in the
appropriate manner in a
seated position as well.
Sometimes patients just aren't
able to lie supine on the
table, and they may more
easily get into a seated
position. So that's good to
know for your future reference
that you could do that
for your patient as well.
So MET of the anterior
fibular head now.
So here is the patient.
The physician is
using his thumb to
contact the anterior
part of that fibular
head, especially.
Fingers are wrapping
around on the
posterior side. But in
this case, remember,
for the posterior fibular
head, the physician was
nudging a little bit
with that index finger
metacarpophalangeal joint.
In this case, the physician
is nudging a little bit
with the thumb on that
anterior proximal, the
fibular head here, okay?
Nudging it to go a little
bit posterior medially,
okay? It's not a heavy-handed
pressure, but it's a part
of the dynamic of what is
going on here. Here you
see the physician controlling
the ankle and the foot.
The second picture, white
arrow showing the direction
that the physician is
engaging into that barrier.
Remember, it is an
anterior fibular head. The
three associated
motions that you learned
for the diagnosis of an
anterior fibular head
are that that diagnosis
prefers or likes
dorsiflexion, eversion,
external rotation, okay?
So you're going to put the
patient, the physician,
into the barrier of
the opposite of that,
plantar flexion, we see
that in number three,
plantar flexion, internal
rotation, and inversion,
okay, of the lower leg,
foot, slash ankle, that
region. Plantar flexion,
internal rotation, inversion.
So that's this inward white
arrow matching white coat,
which is doctors taking
that patient into that
barrier. Again, plantar
flexion, inversion, internal
rotation. The third picture
here shows the dark arrow
pointing outwards as the
physician instructs the
patient to match their
resistance and try and go into
that external rotation,
dorsiflexion, and eversion,
which is the next step
noted here. Again, matching
completely at the same
amount of strength, about 10%
to 25% of the patient's
strength, not too much. I
guide the patient to use
less pressure if you feel
that they're pushing much
too strong. It just needs to
be matching precisely,
which is this line between
the two arrows is showing
exactly matching pressure.
That's what that means there.
As usual, three to five
sets could be more.
You're looking for
improvement in that restricted
barrier. Remember, the
patient likes their fibular
head to go anteriorly. It
was not going posteriorly.
The last set you can
do is kind of a final
engagement of the
barrier motions. And then
always, always reassess.
Here's the link to
the Nicholas Atlas
resource if you need it.
Moving on.
Here's a review table
again from Bates
13th edition. The
link is here for you.
It's talking about the
range of motion of the
ankle joint and the
foot. And here's the list
of the primary muscles
and the motions here.
Patient instructions.
This is the in quotations
part that you want
to take a look at.
Especially going
to be helpful for
you when you're out
on your rotations.
How do you instruct in
layperson's language what
you need the patient
to do? This is going to
be a nice review for you
to incorporate that and
how you're talking to
your patients directly.
And for them, you don't
want to be using a lot
of medical terminology,
which they may not know.
So speaking in a way
clearly that they
can understand. Here's
a link here if you
want to go straight
to the full resource.
Okay, so we're
pairing these next
two. So we have a tibiotalar,
okay, tibia on the talus, okay,
so the ankle joint, basically,
dorsiflexion,
somatic dysfunction.
These are both from
DiGiovanna. On the other page
here to the right, we have
the opposite diagnosis,
a tibiotalar, remember tibia on
the talus, so the ankle joint,
plantarflexion, somatic
dysfunction. We'll
start with the one on
the left. So as we see,
the patient, this is
their patient's right
foot. Okay, physician
in the white coat here.
The patient likes to
dorsiflex. That means
dorsiflexion,
remember from your
diagnosis, toes like
to go towards the head.
Okay,
that's dorsiflex. Patient
likes to dorsiflex.
So here you see the
physician's taking her hand
on the dorsum of the
foot, pushing down,
bringing the patient's
foot into that barrier of
plantar flexion, stabilizing
behind the ankle.
And then, as usual, instructing
the patient to bring
their foot up towards their
head, which would be into
dorsiflexion. As usual, it's
the isometric resistance,
three to five seconds. They
fully, fully relax, and
the patient goes into a new
plantar flexion barrier.
Repeating many times, at
least three to five is
typical, could be more if
needed, and then engaging
one more time the last
time as kind of like
a passive stretch where
the patient won't give
resistance. That's always
okay and always, always
reassessing. Here's the
link for the resource.
On the right hand side
of the page right here,
DG Ivana again, the
opposite diagnosis. Now we
have a plantar flexion,
somatic dysfunction.
What does that mean? That
means the patient likes to
bring their toes down and
away from them, like pointing
the toes, like a dancer
points their toes down, okay?
That would be plantar
flexion. In this case, patient
likes plantar flexion. That's
their somatic dysfunction.
They do not like to
dorsiflexion, bring their toes
towards their head. So you
can see in this picture,
position in the white coat,
patient lying with their right
foot on the table. And it
is an example here of a
right ankle plantar
dysfunction. You can see for the
treatment with muscle energy,
direct treatment, remember,
physicians using her
hand on the plantar side,
plantar surface of the
foot to take that whole
foot into the barrier of
dorsiflexion, stabilizing
at the ankle, pushing
into that barrier of
dorsiflexion. And then
the physician asks the
patient to push into
her hand, okay, towards
her freedom of the
plantar flexion, but it's
isometric, so you won't
see any motion at all,
okay?
As usual,
10 to 25 percent of
the strength, doing
that motion for three
to five seconds,
fully relaxing in between
the sets, reposition
into the new barriers,
and maybe the last
time you engage once more
into that dorsiflexion
barrier, and then as
I was reassessing.
Here's the resource in
the link for you here.
So these were paired. Next
to, now it's a tallocalcaneal
region, right? Tallow,
talus, calcaneal,
calcaneus, okay? So below the
talus is the calcaneus. So
sometimes you may see this
described as subtalar.
Same idea. It's below the
talus. It's the talococaneal
interface or junction
or joint. Okay. And
the diagnoses here are
paired. One for eversion,
one for inversion. These
are both from DiGiovanna.
Muscle energy technique
for the first one,
talococaneal eversion
dysfunction. What does that mean?
So we're saying it's a
right calcaneal eversion
dysfunction. We can see the
physician's on the same side
as the diagnosis. Here's
the patient's right foot.
The patient likes
to evert, okay,
in that talococanial or
subtalar region. So that would
be outwards this way. You
can see the physician is
using her hands, one behind
the ankle, one on the dorsum
of the foot, to bring
that foot inwards. You can
see the toes are kind of
reflexively pointing more inwards
as she brings the whole
foot, and especially that
talococaneal region
inwards, okay?
So it's really, especially
with this hand, bringing
this inwards. This is secondary
because physician's going
to be resisting, especially
with these fingers, but
also a little bit because
as the patient tries to
push outward, kind of the
rest of the foot goes along
for the ride as well. but you
do want to especially have
a focus on this region here
where the calcaneus is.
So you can say bring your
heel laterally, okay,
but you are resisting
at the forefoot as well.
Okay, so grasping the
heel, the forefoot, you're
deviating medially,
okay, and then the
patient's going to try and
push their heel laterally
as highlighted here
in number four, again,
for that three to five
seconds fully relaxing
re-engaging the barriers
as always and then
you know at least three to
five sets and then engaging
the barrier one more time
as your last completing
motion and then reassessing
here's a link to the full
DG Ivana source if you
would like to see that the
opposite diagnosis on the
right hand side of the page now
it is a talc calcaneus
inversion somatic dysfunction.
Of course, that means
patient likes to bring their
calcaneus, okay, the
interface of their talus and
calcaneus into an inward
motion, inversion more so.
Okay, so they like to
come in. So we see in this
picture here that the
physician is contacting, again,
the heel of the foot, the
dorsum of the foot, and using
her hands to bring that
calcaneus outwardly, okay,
and stabilizing at
the foot and being
able to resist. So
the physician grasps
the heel, the other
hand at the forefoot.
This calcaneus in this
case is deviated laterally.
The patient likes to go
inwardly, but the physician
takes them to their barrier
of lateral deviation,
and the patient will try
and bring their heel push
medially. That's an instruction
that you can give to
the patient, again, for
the three to five seconds,
again, 10 to 25 percent
of their strength,
fully relaxing, and
several repetitions.
Once again, usually three
to five, could be more, and
then engaging that barrier
one more time, and then
reassessing. The full resource
is noted here as well.
Okay.
And thank you so much for
your attention. If you
could take the time to fill
out the lab feedback form
after you attend the
lab, we would appreciate
it. We try and improve our
instruction every year for
these labs. And I hope
that this pre-lab lecture
has been informative for
you before you come into
the lab session. Thank
you so much for your time.